hello everyone
today we'll be working through goodie
bag 3 which is on ionic solids
in order to work through this goodie bag
you'll need a conductivity meter
some small measuring cups some
medium-sized cups a small scale
a writing utensil some nitrile gloves
some stirs
and four unique solids today i'll be
using sodium chloride
magnesium sulfate magnesium oxide and
sucrose
our main objective today is to use
solubility and conductivity measurements
to determine if a given solid is an
ionic or covalent
compound and as we do this i'd like you
to think about two questions
first how do solids dissolve in water
and second
what factors may influence how
conductive a given solid is in water
so first we're going to look at the
solubility of our solids in water
and to do this we're going to dissolve
one gram of each solid
in 30 milliliters of water i've already
weighed out my solids here
and i've also already weighed out my
water notice how i'm wearing a pair of
nitrile gloves
the compounds that i'm working with
today aren't that dangerous but just as
general safety it's good to wear gloves
when handling compounds
so i'm going to pour each solute into
each respective cup of water
and stir and mix for about a minute to
two minutes and see
if the compound dissolves
so after one to two minutes of stirring
and dissolving you can see that our
magnesium oxide right here
has not dissolved in our water you can
see a very clear boundary between the
solute which is settled at the bottom of
the cup
and the water which is on top if you
compare that to
our sodium chloride though if you look
very carefully you can see that
our solute has dissolved very well in
our water
so the next thing we'll be doing is
measuring the conductivity
of our compounds when dissolved in water
and to do that
we're going to be using a handy-dandy
conductivity meter that i have right
here
so i have some cups of water prepared
here to be used as both
a baseline correction when we're
measuring our conductivity
of our compounds and as a water bath to
clean our probe in between measurements
okay so first i'm going to turn on my
conductivity measure
and i'm going to make sure that my units
are set to microsiemens per centimeter
or some equivalent unit and first i'm
going to measure a baseline
of just regular water here i have tap
water here and so when i do that
i see that
i'm measuring around 900 microsiemens
per centimeter so that is the
conductivity of my water as
is and i'm going to use that as a
baseline when i'm measuring the
conductivity
of my other compounds
so since this is water it's already
clean and now i'm going to measure my
sodium chloride which is right here
and so right now i'm reading around 4
700 microsiemens per centimeter for my
sodium chloride
i'm going to take note of that and
eventually when i'm collecting my data
i'm going to subtract
my water based line from this value here
make sure in between each measurement
that you dip the probe in a water bath
to clean it
and you can continue on with the rest of
your measurements
so the last experiment we're going to do
today is to measure the solubility of
our compounds in water
except with two grams instead of one
gram so i've measured out an additional
one gram of each solid here
and i'm just gonna pour each one into
each respective cup mix
and stir and after one to two minutes
i'm gonna see if each compound is
dissolved
so again we have our magnesium oxide
after round two
of solubility again we can see that our
solute has not dissolved in water
there's a very clear boundary between
the water on top and the solute on the
bottom so in this case
round one the solubility and round two
solubility look identical but it may not
be the case
for our other three solutes all right so
now that we've finished our last
solubility test
let's put all our data our first
solubility test
our conductivity test and our second
solubility test on the board
so here we have a chart of all the data
from our experiments
i have the compounds that we use going
down right here and i have
solubility here at one gram and two
grams and conductivity after water
subtraction here
so before going into this data first
thing i would like us to notice is that
for sodium chloride and for magnesium
sulfate
these conductivity values are much lower
than i expected
this should be closer to ten thousand
microsiemens and this should be closer
to eight thousand micro siemens percent
meter
um but the fact that we're able to
measure conductivity for these
respective compounds
uh gives us insight into what type of
compounds they are
so first if we look at sodium chloride
we could see that at both one gram and
two grams
um our sodium chloride was able to
dissolve in water
and we're able to measure conductivity
readings for this
this means our sodium chloride was able
to dissociate into ions when dissolved
in water
and this is an extra check for us to
determine that sodium chloride is indeed
an ionic
compound
next we can look at magnesium oxide and
we can see that from my
magnesium oxide at one gram and two
grams
we were we weren't able to dissolve our
magnesium oxide water
and not only that because of that we
weren't able to measure any conductivity
but we know that magnesium oxide is an
ionic
compound just from our understanding of
bonding so we have to think
more closely about why this is the case
so magnesium oxide and sodium chloride
are both ionic compounds
but magnesium oxide has a much higher
lattice energy than sodium chloride
this means that when magnesium oxide is
placed in water
uh it's more energetically favorable for
it to stay
as a solid than it is to disassociate
into ions of magnesium
and oxygen so magnesium oxide is still
an ionic compound but its lattice energy
is high enough
for such that it does not dissolve and
does not give us conductivity
measurements
so it's still ionic now we can look at
magnesium sulfate
and we see that for one gram we do get
some solubility
and at two grams we get uh no solubility
it was not able to dissolve and we're
able to measure some conductivity
this means that magnesium sulfate
dissociated
into respective ions and were able to
measure some conductivity well in water
but magnesium sulfate has a limited
solubility in water
which is why at two grams it wasn't able
to dissolve completely
so magnesium sulfate is still in the
compound
finally if we look at sucrose we see
that we're able to get
one gram of sucrose to dissolve in water
and two grams of sucrose
was able to dissolve in water but we
were not able to get any conductivity
this means that sucrose dissolved in
water but
did not dissociate into respective ions
so if you think about the structure of
sucrose
sucrose has a bunch of non excuses
has a bunch of polar groups on it which
make it
able to dissolve in water but sucrose
does not dissociate into ions
which is why we were not able to measure
any conductivity so sucrose
is a covalent compound
so by using our knowledge of bonding and
our solubility and conductivity data
we're able to affirm the identity
of our compounds that is whether or not
they are ionic or covalent
so today we looked at how the type and
strength of bonding of a solid
influences its properties specifically
we looked at how these
aspects of bonding influence the
solubility
and conductivity of these solids in
water